وبالحديث عن جيمس، قمت
بتسجيل مقطع فيديو ونشرته على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي،
وقد نال بعض الاهتمام
واصفًا ما تراه في غزة على
وجه الخصوص مع الأطفال، فلنشاهد
ذلك
سريعًا المزيد من الأطفال المصابين بجراح
الحرب والحروق والشظايا  إن
تناثر العظام المكسورة
في أجسادهم من قبل أصحاب
النفوذ
هو السماح بقتل
الأطفال، هذه حرب على
الأطفال، طعام محدود، ماء، دواء،
هذا ما تصفه مجرد
فوضى، كيف تعيش بهذه الطريقة، ما هو
المزاج الناتج عن هؤلاء؟  الأشخاص الذين
تتحدثون إليهم
بذعر تام، لا أستطيع، لقد كنت للتو
في المستشفى مع استمرار القصف في
كل مكان، ويجب أن أقول، حيث كنت هناك،
جاء 10 أطفال مصابين بجروح الحرب
العاشرة ربما في بضع ساعات بجراح
مروعة  جروح بشظايا في
الدماغ إصابات في العين حروق من
الدرجة الثالثة إنها منطقة حرب
المستشفى
أه لذلك هناك ذعر بين الناس
بالتأكيد يتغير كل ساعة هنا
الناس لا يعرفون إلى أين يذهبون
هم تقريبا في  الأطفال في
المستشفى إيزابيل يمسكون بي،
الأمهات يمسكن بي قائلين خذوني
إلى مكان آمن، فتاة صغيرة أمسكت بي
وحاولت أن أتوقف لحظة دائمًا كان
لديها زجاجتان مياه فارغتان وهي
في المستشفى، من فضلك هل يمكنك وضع بعض
الماء فيهما  الماء في الصنابير مالح
ولا تستطيع شربه لذا فهو أمر
مطلق، يُطلب من الناس المذعورين
الانتقال من النقطة أ إلى النقطة ب، وكأن الأمر يشبه
لعبة الشطرنج إلا أنه
ينتهي بموت الأطفال.
المناطق الآمنة ليست لعبة بالنسبة لهم، أعتقد أن
إيزابيل مهمة جدًا، إنها
رواية كاذبة وخطيرة،
فالناس ليس لديهم وسائل
النقل ولا يعرفون إلى أين من
المفترض أن يذهبوا إلى أماكنهم في الصحراء.
ليس لديهم ماء، ليس لديهم طعام،
ليس لديهم حماية في هذه الأماكن،
ولذلك عندما يصابون بسيقان
المرض، وعندما يهدأون
ويصلون إلى هذه الأماكن يتم قصفهم،
إنها رواية خطيرة للغاية
يتم مشاركتها أنهم ليسوا مناطق آمنة
ستكون مناطق
الموت بشكل صحيح واسمحوا لي أن أقدم
المزيد من السياق حول أنك تتحدث
عن تلك المنشورات التي أسقطها جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
مع تلك المناطق المرقمة التي تطلب من الناس
الذهاب إلى المناطق الآمنة ولكن بناءً على ما
تقوله، يبدو الأمر كذلك  كما لو أنه لا توجد
منطقة آمنة يمكنهم الذهاب إليها، كما أنها
كانت عبارة عن رموز QR في غزة حيث يكون
الاتصال بالإنترنت متقطعًا، لذا حتى
الحصول على هذه الخريطة أمر
مشكوك فيه، فلا يوجد مكان في إيزابيل،
ولا يوجد إمكانية الوصول، وقد تحصل على شبكة Wi-Fi
إذا كنت  "نحن في منزل لا يوجد به 4G أو 3G أو
5G، لذلك يحصل الناس على هذه الأشياء وبعد
خمس دقائق توجد
قنبلة أو في طريقهم إلى هناك
توجد قنبلة وقد
تذكروا بالفعل أن هؤلاء الأشخاص قد
قصفت منازلهم  في الشمال ورأيت أحد
أفراد الأسرة وأختًا وأمًا تموت، ثم
انتقلوا إلى ملجأ ربما
تعرض للقصف، وقد نزلوا إلى الجنوب،
وهناك حالة من الذعر بين الناس هنا
لأنهم ببساطة لا يعرفون الآن أين
هم.  من المفترض أن نذهب إلى
أه نعم وقد قال نتنياهو إن
الحرب ستستمر ولذا أقتبس أم أننا
نحقق جميع أهدافنا ماذا
تستنتج من ذلك وماذا يعني ذلك بالنسبة
للمدنيين الفلسطينيين دمار يجب على العالم
الآن أن يكون على دراية بـ  حجم هذا نحن
6000 طفل قتلوا الآن
وليس هناك شك في أن بعض الأطفال الذين رأيتهم هذا
الصباح مدى شدة جروحهم،
إيزابيل، لن يتمكنوا من
النجاة خلال اليوم حيث يوجد
العديد من الأطفال هناك، لذا فإن فكرة
استمرار الأمر  الحرب على الأطفال
ستستمر بينما العالم يراقب،
أعتقد أنه يتعين علينا أن نقبل الآن في
مجتمع متحضر تلك الديمقراطيات التي
لها رأي هنا بأن الصمت هو الصمت
تواطؤ، وعليها أن تنظر في
عيون الأمهات اللاتي فقدن
القدرة  لحماية أطفالهم من
الطلاب الصغار
والأدمغة الرائعة التي أواجهها طوال
الوقت والذين يشعرون بالخوف التام، عليهم أن
يقبلوا أنهم
يسمحون بموت هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
تحدثنا أنا وأنت، وكان هناك
اثنان آخران كبيران جدًا  قصف
إيزابيل، ربما يكون هذا هو
اليوم الأكثر كثافة الذي شهدناه، بالتأكيد، إنه
اليوم الأكثر كثافة الذي شهده الجنوب،
وهي رواية أخرى سمعناها
أننا لن نفعل ذلك، ربما قيل لنا
للحكومات أننا ربما لن نسمح
بما يحدث  لقد حدث في الجنوب ما حدث في
الشمال حسنًا، ما يحدث في
الجنوب يمكنني أن أشهد على ذلك